sonntags um 16 uhr ist kuchen zeit bei
vox
[Musik]
ich freue mich auf meine neue sendung
und auf euch
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
welches heute gibt's ein süßes rezept
mit einem hefeteig also mein
lieblingsteil und zwar habe ich hier
nichts gebacken nein nicht nur zur
bezirke mit brombeeren in einer paket
form so könnte wirklich auch mal das
baguette gleich nutzen um nicht nur
paket zu machen sondern auch süße
teilchen und es sieht wirklich super
hübsch aus und wenn man die später auf
schneidet und sie auch richtig schön
ich bereite zuerst einmal den hefeteig
zu und zeige ich die zutaten für den
hefeteig brauche ich einen würfel hefe
80 gramm zucker einen esslöffel warmes
wasser ein eigelb ein teelöffel salz
etwas vanille extrakt 250 milliliter
lauwarme mit 500 gramm mehl und 100
gramm weiche butter zuerst fertig jetzt
die hefe mit dem wasser und etwas zucker
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die hefe mischung in meine
rührschüssel gemeinsam mit dem
restlichen zucker dem eigelb dem salz
und vanille extrakt da kommt noch die
milch dazu das mehl und die weiche
butter und jetzt kann sich aus allen
zutaten einen richtig schönen und
geschmeidigen hefeteig nähten
[Musik]
der hefeteig dürfte jetzt etwa sieben
minuten kneten je länger umso besser und
jetzt ist auch richtig schön geschmeidig
und da kommt wirklich auch auf die mail
sorte darauf an eine zuschauerin hatte
mal geschrieben dass die hilfe direkt
immer zu trocken wird
ich nehme mir immer das phänomen von
globus und das braucht einfach ein
bisschen weniger flüssigkeit und daher
habe ich jetzt hier zum beispiel grad
noch mal zwei drei esslöffel mehl dazu
gegeben weil der teig einfach zu feucht
war
so ist jetzt richtig perfekt und es ist
einfach auch so ein bisschen 50
milliliter milch oder weniger ohne ein
esslöffel meerwasser oder weniger es
kommt auf die größe des eingriffs an
also hefeteig ist immer auch so ein
bisschen natürlich gefühlssache der es
richtig schön weich
der kommt wieder zurück in die
rührschüssel da kann ich ihnen abdecken
und für etwa eine stunde aufgehen
der hefeteig ist wunderschön aufgegangen
einer meiner lieblings zeige und den
gebe ich jetzt hier auch eine silikon
matte und teilen in vier teile
[Musik]
ihr könnt natürlich darauf auch einen
großen job machen und den auf einem ganz
normalen backblech backen so dass rolle
ich jetzt schön lang aus mit bisschen
mädel und jetzt kann ich hier die zucker
zimt mischung machen und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier flüssige butter braunen
zucker und etwas zimt und das ganze wird
jetzt schön verrührt schön kalorienarm
weight watchers rezept und damit wird
die platte zu finden
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann jetzt ihr zum
beispiel tom bernd darauf geben oder
auch blaubeeren oder andere früchte oder
zugmantel und jetzt das ganze schön
aufrollen
[Musik]
jetzt die rolle halbieren und dann könnt
ihr sie flechten oder einfach so um
einander legen
[Musik]
und ich bin das jetzt zum backen die
parkfläche da hab ich jetzt zwei stück
einfach aneinander gelegt und die passen
echt ideal auf das backblech mit den
löchern und wegen der butter nämlich
jetzt einfach noch eine dauer bank folie
dazwischen und kann das praktisch jetzt
auch schon fest
das ist die eine variante und jetzt
zeige ich euch noch eine zweite
[Musik]
bei der variante könnte zum beispiel
eine schere nehmen und hier oben einfach
ein bisschen einschneiden wer möchte
kann den job noch mit butter bestreichen
und bevor ich ihnen dann in den ofen
schiebe las ich in abgedeckt noch mal
eine halbe stunde ruhen die hefezöpfe
sind jetzt gebacken und entweder könnt
ihr sie so lassen oder mit süßem schnee
bestreuen
oder noch einen bus drüber machen für
den guss habe ich jetzt hier bin ich hab
frischkäse zitronensaft und puderzucker
und die zutaten werden einfach kurz im
mixer zerkleinert und jetzt könnt ihr
den bus nehmen und einfach darüber
träufeln
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den job schneiden
ich bin meinen fans warten gespannt
darauf teller oder aus der hand ja warum
bayerisch rausgefahren
ich liebe ja hefegebäck wenn es noch
schön warm ich mach eins gefolgt ist ein
ernstes die nicht so heiß nein ich nur
war ich es wahrscheinlich in die
brombeere weißen ich liebhabe geweckt
werden zwar modern und schmeckt super
aber nicht heißt ja wir sind abkühlen
kann man sich schon noch lassen ok ich
gebe es so ein bisschen abkühlen was
lassen
ich finde jedenfalls eine richtig coole
idee vor allem einfach mal den hefezopf
auf dem backblech zu backen
was sagst du dazu nikolaus gab so und
dann schöne runde schneiden hat man
kleine stücke statt zum großen hefezopf
und falls ihr das rezept nachmachen
möchte egal mit welchen bären ob jetzt
brombeeren gar keine beeren oder andere
wäre dann findet ihr das rezept auf
salehs - blog.de brauchen wir als frauen
wäre doch mal ganz gut passt vielleicht
nicht so aber spiele aber ich bin okay
kriegs anfangs stück noch ne also viel
spaß dann nachmachen
[Musik]
sonntags und 16 uhr ist kuchen zeit
aalborg
[Musik]
ich freue mich auf meine neue sendung
und auf euch